oh no manufacturing's gone never gonna
bring it back just like the wall they're
not really trying oh we know we can do
as graphene or if you study this
chemical it's pure carbon you can get it
out of the air out of the carbon dioxide
in the air and turn into this building
material graft pure carbon it's a
hexagonal lattice so it looks like a
honeycomb but it's one atom thick it's
200 times stronger than steel it's pure
carbon it's electrically conductive you
can use it for wiring capacitators to
use it for Batteries touch screen
wallpaper you can make buildings if you
drop it this room won't blow up right
it's just it's just dust it's like
carbon dust and you can you can like mix
it with other metals to make super
strong materials lightweight
electrically conducted we'll like fix
our roads with it we'll fix our Railways
with it we'll make new stronger
railroads that don't bend and cause
derailment why do you have a little jar
of it Tim bought it for me as a gift
because he's obsessed with it but I will
say this it's going to be 100 years in
the future everyone's gonna have flying
cars and jet packs everything will be
made of graphene and there's going to be
a statue of Ian in the middle of like
New York City